what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down where I bring on different
guests to talk about feminism men and
women's relationships and other topics
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell let's get this video
to 2 000 likes that's the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams also get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today you know
you guys know my opinion the breakdown
of the family everything is be all
because women got the right to vote get
yourself a t-shirt all the women will
come up to you and say how awesome you
are so welcome to the show guys can you
give the audience a little background
I'm starting with you Paul yeah I'm Paul
Elam uh my website is paulilam.com I've
been involved in working around men and
men's issues for nearly 40 years now my
YouTube channel is an earformen.com and
you can also find me at paulilam.com
forward slash XY crew for our men's
groups that deal with these very topics
every day of the week okay so I'm a
divorced mother of three remarried
um all my children are adults now and
gainfully employed and responsible
citizens I don't even know how that
happened but yeah no I I've been
involved in men's rights and
anti-feminism for about well since about
2010 when I started discussing the
issues online and what led me to be
interested in them was that I was going
through my divorce at that time and you
know how when you when you divorce you
have this extremely long detailed list
right down to every last little thing of
what they did wrong but if you don't
want to have something like that happen
again you actually have to try and
figure out what you did wrong and
because it's never only just one person
screwing up and ruining a marriage so I
stumbled I was looking for answers and I
stumbled across a men's website called
spearhead and I started participating in
the comments section there and it was
brutal it was absolutely brutal but fair
but totally fair and I started reading
all of these articles about things like
domestic violence and sexual assault and
false allegations and divorce law and
alimony and child support laws and all
kinds of things like that and I thought
well this is not the world I want my
sons to grow up in and it's definitely
not even the world that I want my
daughter to grow up in because if you if
you completely destroy the trust between
that men have for women how can your
daughter be able to go out and form a
relationship with someone who's
trustworthy if he's always if he's
pretending to trust her not to screw him
over then it's because he's planning to
screw her over right so I I was just
like no no this is not a good way to
form families and have a functioning
society and so I just started talking
about it and you know there was an
aspect of someone is wrong on the
internet uh as well it's funny when you
first I can't I can't leave people to
say stupid things and then just walk
away with nobody pushing back on them so
well it's funny when you first like get
into the red pill space as a chair
because like I think we're just so used
to being like pandered to 24 7 and you
hear it you're like oh wow this is how
this is what guys think and it's kind of
like a shot it's kind of like a shock at
first but then I don't know how it was
for you but for me I was like oh this is
actually helpful to know I was like this
is actually like useful information I
thought there's two different kinds of
women out there that get in into the red
pill space and there are those who look
at the pushback from men and say well
give them what they're living with and
working with every day this is
understandable uh it's not pleasant it's
not pretty but I get it this is the way
they feel and that there's lots of women
that get into the red pill space Also
that get some of that pushback and all
of a sudden we're evil and we're
everything feminists have uh have always
said we were so I like those guys out
there given the pushback for the for the
reason that it really gets the
non-hackers out of the way so that women
who really want to speak to these issues
trillion it's nice to have them they're
they're a very very very effective
vetting committee basically you know if
you're if you're real you'll stick
around and you know I saw a couple of
women who were like totally on board
with the guys at the spearhead until you
know one of them said something
particularly insulting about women and
or maybe was rude to them and then they
pulled their woman card and said well
you can't be rude to me I'm a woman and
you know you don't treat women like that
and they were like yeah you can go [__]
off you know and and they would get
booted out and it's like no you can't
you can't these guys are being honest
about how they feel and they are often
being brutally honest because that's the
only way anybody's ever gonna care is if
this guy is so shockingly honest that it
snaps you out of your uh your malaise
and you actually have to pay attention
to him it's it's like it's like the
difference between someone I'm a man
standing on the sidewalk yelling at
people well you got to pay attention to
that guy as opposed to a man lying on
the sidewalk you know under a pile of
newspapers you know slowly dying yeah um
well and I had people just walk past I
used to when I first like started
watching the stuff I I would say like oh
like why do they say it like that and
then I realized I'm like oh it's just
how guys talk but we're so used to being
like pandered to that we're just not
used to like the bluntness of it but I
think it's good I feel like I feel like
it's like overall it's a good thing
because then you kind of understand how
guys like think around you a little bit
better yeah number one too the guys get
pushed back on this I I practice a lot
of that bluntness in the work I do and I
can tell you there's no shortage of guys
out there pushing back on me saying I
need to be worn feral instead of lilam
uh that just sort of part of the vetting
process for men I think yeah no and and
I I have a real hard time with you know
when you look at Warren Farrell I
imagine two parents right so you have
you have the one parent who calmly and
quietly explains to the child you know
why you're having a time out because you
you know and why you need to to clean
your room or why you need to you know go
to school on be on time and why you need
to do things and you know be very
reasonable and very calm and very quiet
and then every once in a while you need
a parent who's just gonna put his foot
down right and say no this far no
further smarten up or you're going to
get your ass hand and I mean you cannot
have a men's movement populated only by
Warren Farrells you need the tip of the
spear you need the spearhead of people
who are rude and in your face and
shocking and blunt and brutally honest
right to basically soften up the
audience to be willing to even listen to
and entertain the positions of the war
in ferals out there because otherwise
you know Warren Farrell is just never
going to get anywhere yeah they say I'm
really mean so oh they all say annually
mean too so you guys are cupcakes
such a cool oh I don't know if you know
her Sachi cool she's a Canadian uh
journalist but she works for uh she was
working for BuzzFeed and she put me on a
Netflix special and I sat down for 90
minutes with her and then about 40
minutes into the interview she says well
you called me a [__] and I was like did
I she's like yeah like six times and I'm
like are you it says are you denying it
and I'm like no it sounds like something
I'd say I just don't recall I've called
a lot of people [__] and uh and she's
like like and that's my question and I'm
like okay and then she says well do you
still think I'm a [__] and I'm I'm like
yeah kinda you know and I burst out
laughing right I wish I had been more on
the ball I would have like looked at my
imaginary watch and said well we've been
here for 40 minutes and you haven't
given me a reason to change my mind so
you know and she just sat through the
whole thing looking like she I just
forced her to eat bird poop it was great
my question today I'm curious so what is
you guys's opinion of feminism as a
whole it has never not been rotten okay
you know I don't know if I can add
anything to that it's it's been a hate
movement from its inceptions starting
with Seneca Falls all the way up to
today it is populated by a lot of women
who have big time issues with men and
they express it politically through
feminism I'd say going back further than
that going back all the way to Mary
woolstonecraft yeah that she had if you
actually read about her life she was
deeply Disturbed probably borderline
personality disorder or bipolar or
something like that paranoid uh she
hated men she hated her father and she
never got married she had a child out of
wedlock she tried to kill herself when
she found that okay at this point it's
it's difficult to be a single mother so
I'm going to try and coerce the man who
impregnated me into marrying me and he
wouldn't do it because she was crazy and
so then she tried to kill herself with
this six-year-old or nine-year-old girl
daughter who was depending on her and
because this guy said no I don't want to
be married to you and I'm guessing he
was paying her some sort of uh support
but it's like I'm I'm looking at that
that is that was the proto-feminist that
gave birth to what occurred in Seneca
Falls uh 75 years later and that I mean
when you look at that document the
Declaration of Sentiments and you you
read that one line the history of
mankind is a history of repeated user
patients and oppressions of by man
against women having indirect object the
establishment of an absolute tyranny
over her right that is what they were
saying that was their description of the
world as it stood in 1850 and then they
just go from there and they make this
list of all of the ways in which men
have wronged women and of course none of
the ways in which men have done right by
women none of the the sort of the
trade-offs that were made uh in terms of
yes men have custody of the children by
by default I mean like there are ways of
getting around that but fathers have
custody of their children by default but
that's because fathers paid for their
children they were the sole people
legally responsible for supporting those
children so they they got them because
they paid for them but doesn't say
anything about that and you look at all
of the ways that they began to dismantle
all of those Norms right well man they
switched they didn't say oh let's go to
equal shared custody on the part of
mothers and fathers no it was custody to
the mother Tender Years Doctrine but oh
no reason to touch that that whole
child's important alimony thing and the
father being the Sole Provider for the
all the necessaries of his children and
the head of their household which is now
the mother right oh no no reason to look
at that no reason to think about that
right so or change any of that so they
really pulled uh pulled one over on
society and every single thing that they
did with coverture was they they took
away all of the all of the handicaps on
women all of the uh restrictions on
women all of the limitations on women
and handed them everything they wanted
and then kept all of the obligation and
responsibility and culpability and all
of those things on men well I mean all
of that is factually correct
um and most of this [__] happened before
women got Tipsy you know it's important
to keep all this in mind because what
you'll hear most common even from
alleged conservatives today is that
feminism was a movement with all the
right ideas that somehow took a turn
South and went in the wrong direction at
some point maybe in the late 1960s early
70s something like that of course that's
a fallacy feminism was rotten from the
beginning I know that Karen's writer
predates Seneca Falls but in Seneca
Falls even men were invited to attend
that convention and sit in the back with
their mouths shut from the very
beginning that was the rules that the
women put away at Seneca Falls it's
never been an inclusive movement that
was about any kind of Justice or
anything of that sort it was always
about women getting all the power they
could and exercising it against men and
this is exactly what we see playing out
in the social landscape today and
politically and legally across the board
feminism has poisoned our society in
many ways but I think it's also really
important not to forget that feminism is
one side of a coin gynocentrism as a
whole is tells a more complete picture
because you've got people like our
friends at the daily wire and other
places who are saying they're
anti-feminist and then turning around
and just parroting all sorts of
adulation and deference to women and
painting women as victims using all the
same language that feminism uses just
from a slightly different angle and when
you object to that they'll say you're
like the feminist it's it's an
interesting Dynamic
you're not a real man if you don't get
married absolutely that Meme the
unfortunately the political right in I
think North America if there's is there
care is there any more political right
in Canada that exists anymore yes okay
good it's there but what you get from
these guys is that
they will not talk about changing family
law or fixing family law they will talk
about men needing to get married but the
moment
they need to step up and man up and and
you know take the hint or whatever step
up to the plaint as fathers even if they
catch fastballs between the eyes they
need to to step up and do that and at
the same time they're saying that
they're anti-feminist it's it's a
strange mix I think I think I think it's
interesting too to note that I think
wasn't it Ronald Reagan who who
basically passed no fault divorce in
California the first governor to do that
yeah yeah and and it's like well okay
yeah I can understand having no fault
divorce right you know like you don't
have to prove that he beat you you don't
have to prove that he raped you you
don't have to prove that he uh was uh
abusive or abandoned the family you
don't have to prove any of that you just
have irreconcilable differences and you
can divorce him you know and you can do
that unilaterally without having to
prove fault okay so you walk away with
your share a fair share of the marital
assets that you both accumulated during
the marriage and that's it that's it
right and you share custody of your kids
because if it if no one if he if it's no
fault then you're basically saying he's
not at fault either right so you walk
away you don't have to you don't have to
take him out for the rest of his life
there's you know like the whole lifetime
alimony thing well I started I'm looking
at too often uh keep that going so it's
infuriating to me where you have this
well Republican you get in bed with
feminists
super awesome bedfellows there but you
know like Rick Scott in um in Florida he
twice vetoed a bill that would get rid
of lifetime alimony and at the behest of
the National Organization for Women
that's what he did and it's like because
he thinks that you know a man's place is
to be supporting women and you can think
that all you want right and I don't have
any problem with that right like I live
in a in a marriage right now where my
man financially supports the whole
household and I take care of him and you
know the home uh as inept leased often
that is but I I look after all of those
things that I take care of paying the
bills I take care of all the domestic
stuff I take care of all the cooking and
he needs a lot of cooking and all of
those things I I don't have a problem
with even organizing society around
those principles you just can't have a
society that's organized around those
principles where you pretend that they
don't exist and you make laws that don't
enforce those principles you make laws
that actually counter uh counteract
those principles so it's it's like
basically we have this thing where it's
like a woman can divorce a man in
Florida for any reason or no reason at
all and walk away and and he has to pay
her for the rest of his life and he
never gets to retire his retirement is
the day that he pulls out a gun and does
that right and uh so it's I I'm just
looking at it and I'm thinking you know
if you want if you want as a
traditionalist republican right who
believes in gender roles and who
believes in you know this uh gender
distribution of Labor and who believes
in you know marriage and who believes in
all of those then pick that pick that
and make laws that reinforce that right
don't pick that right in terms of what
you're willing to say socially and then
you know and then just do a whole bunch
of stuff that completely contradicts it
and makes it impossible to actually
establish in real life so but here's the
here's the problem that we keep facing
with conservatives all the time is that
they will again they'll insist that men
step up and volunteer for the abuse but
they will never speak about family core
Sports yeah because they do not have the
spines to stand up to women they will
not put themselves in a role of being
and seeing in competition or conflict
with women so that all they're left with
is you need to get married no matter
what no matter how bad the deal is no
matter how corrupt the courts are no
matter how lopsided the laws are you
need to step up and do this and by the
way when you say we'll fix the courts
first they go dead silent it's it's
absolutely the hypocrisy and the lack of
spine and conservatives over this matter
is just staggering yeah well it's so
it's so crazy because I I like you know
when I first got into the red pill space
I didn't really understand people's like
problem with marriage I was like what's
the problem my parents are married
and then I started like going into I
started researching it and I started um
working on my divorce documentary and I
had this like realization I'm like a lot
of guys would have been better off if
they never got married or had kids
because I realized I'm like the women
will turn the kids against the dot
anyways and and God knows who the mom
the baby mother stepmom whatever brings
like what Dad is or what male she BR he
she brings parade of uncles yeah yeah
exactly and so I'm like no there's
because some of the guys it's like
really sad when you talk to them they're
like they're they're so like there's
just nothing like a guy who who can't
see his kids like it's just like the
most devastating thing where he'll be
like a mile away from them and he can't
see them and he feels so powerless from
this court system I'm like [__] if I was
a guy I don't know if I'd sign up for
this even if it was just uh like because
you know they'll always try to downplay
the stats like they'll try to like you
know because I would argue that she just
didn't meet the right woman yeah I mean
like they'll be like they'll be like
find a girl that prays him like have you
seen the [__] that pray nowadays like
I'm not trying to be rude but like I
mean I I've seen Kate like I I just got
to the point where I couldn't find a
right woman that I hadn't seen [__] over
a guy I'm like I found the Muslim girl I
found the Eastern Europeans that are
supposed to be better I felt like the
Russian agent came over here no it's all
of them I'm like it's just us
and so you know it just kind of made me
realize that [__] like if I was a guy I
wouldn't sign up the only solution if
they really want to bring families
together is to switch the courts because
it's like this is two generations of men
at least that have been screwed over by
this court system so you know guys are
logical they kind of weigh the pros and
cons they're like I can't even get two
kids out of this anymore they're like
and I have to risk it all for one yeah
they'll hate your guts by the time
they're 20. yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah no and and why would you do it when
you've got you know casual sex and I
tell my boys right you know if you're
gonna engage in that you bring your own
condoms you don't use the ones she has
right you bring your own condoms you use
them you take them into the bathroom
after words you rinse them out in the
hottest water that comes out of the tap
and then you throw them in the trash
don't flush them down the toilet because
that's disgusting and somebody has to
scrape all that stuff off of the intake
valves at the Water Treatment Center so
you know don't make it hard for other
men is basically what I'm saying but but
yeah you need to protect yourself and
like my sister when I started making my
videos my older sister she's six years
older than me she said she you know she
had had the talk with her daughter who
was you know uh 13 or something at the
time about you know the talk about boys
and you know staying staying on the
straight and narrow and not getting into
temptation and not letting anybody talk
you into doing anything you shouldn't be
doing and all of that stuff right and
she says and then you started making
videos and I started realizing I have to
have that talk with my boys too and so
she's got you know his her her boys are
sandwiched in between two daughters and
and so she gave them the talk about
watching out for users watching out for
women who are gonna lie expect them to
lie when they say they're on birth
control expect them to be lying and
predict that you know they will sperm
Jack you if they can you know because
and maybe only one in a thousand women
will do this but that one in a thousand
means uh one hundred and fifty thousand
dollar 26 year amortized baby mortgage
and I think that that speaks to a bigger
issue too than just marriage I mean what
we're talking about here is the
fundamental lack of trust trust that
that we can have that men can have in
women nowadays because the potential
damage doesn't isn't limited to marriage
I mean there's paternity fraud all kinds
of things that go on all the time
between women and men that this Society
won't talk about but it fundamentally
boils down to that relationships with
with men who are unconscious about going
about them are a very dangerous thing to
get involved in and they can be very
dangerous even if you are conscious uh
about what's going on and the
hypocritical thing too is that you know
when they talk about paternity fraud and
okay so you know she had the milkman's
kids but you know he was their dad and
he raised them as his own and he didn't
even know they weren't his until you
know he found out when one of the kids
needed a kidney or something like that
and you know oh you know so but I mean
it it shouldn't matter DNA shouldn't
matter and I'm I'm looking at this these
two women in France about 10 years ago
whose babies were Switched at the
hospital and they got like two and a
half million euros in compensation for
that because they discovered it when
their daughters were 15. that you know
and they loved their daughters but it
mattered the DNA mattered to them each
of them went home with a daughter it
shouldn't DNA shouldn't matter well
apparently it matters to women so what
is gynocentrism I'm starting to learn
like is that just like putting women on
a pedestal essentially that's one
definition I think it's a long-standing
for about the past thousand years since
the what am I looking for the Advent of
romantic chivalry blended with our
natural biological predispositions but
it basically boils down to women matter
men don't everything about women matters
their health matters more it's why we
have a department on women's health in
the government and and nothing for men
uh it's why the courts are biased it's
why the relationship rules are rigged to
disadvantaged men from the beginning we
are supposed to be like seals clapping
our flippers together for a piece of
fish and balancing a beach model in our
nose in order to win the the favor of
women I mean there's a million different
ways that gynocentrism is expressed but
I think that really does sum it up it's
just about women being elevated uh in
importance over men in all matters I
think I think when when you look because
I I look at it less from a sociological
or historical context and more from an
evolutionary biological context and I
think think that when it comes to
patriarch patriarchy and gynocentrism
are effectively fed by the same core
impulses that are determined by our wet
wear right so this is our operating
system it's not the software that it's
not the apps that we install afterwards
you know culture and stuff like that the
apps can be very bad and I think that
modern gynocentrism is very much a set
of really toxic apps but this is a
fundamental operating system uh it's the
it's what got us through the pla places
to the mass extinction during the
pleistocene um which is patriarchy is
basically the recognition of of
paternity and gender roles right gender
division of labor in in terms of
patriarchy is is the ring of soldiers
and Hunters that surrounds the village
and gynocentrism is the women who are
kept safe within that Village to get
down to their job of producing more
people right of producing Offspring so
when you look at when you look at it in
that way you can see it as something
that is actually it's it's
evolutionarily it makes sense it's you
know it's why six other hominid species
went extinct during the pleistocene
um the Neanderthals being the most
famous they didn't have a gendered
division of labor men women and children
all engaged in big game hunting and
their skeletons have the fractures to
prove it right female male and child so
you're looking at you know once they
came Acro and they didn't have any
domestic Arts at all other than what
they borrowed from from us so basically
what you're looking at is something that
is actually really really well
established to promote survival to
promote Community uh cohesion right this
gender division of labor that the gender
roles for men and women men protect
humans women produce humans right and
and that's just that's just how it works
and it worked really well then you got
into all of these stages where well we
can give women a little bit more freedom
oh well we can give women a little bit
more power oh we can give women a little
bit more choice we can give women the
ability to say no when their husband
says duck or hide but we're going to
still hold him responsible if she takes
an arrow to the chest right
um he's still the one to blame because
he couldn't protect her right even
though she didn't have to obey him and
so I mean you're looking at all of these
Corruptions of these very deeply
ingrained impulses that we have that
we're born with that are very hard to
purge this is why it's taken 150 years
or more for men to actually start
defending themselves against feminism
and against this campaign of anti-male
hate is because they have it it's
counter to their natural impulses which
are to protect and provide for women you
know because that that's the best way to
protect and provide for their offspring
right their their own offspring and
their communities so it's like you you
look at it and it's it's just this
massive hijacking of massive corrupt
hijacking of our natural impulses that
are in my opinion pragmatic and morally
neutral and we've just changed them and
changed them and changed them and change
them and always to ease up the rules for
women and then somebody has to pick up
that slack so the rules get more more
harsh on men you know and like back in
the day uh when um when you had uh if a
woman was raped it was at least against
the law right and it was against the law
because she might end up with a baby
right that's basically the reason it was
against the law she might end up with a
baby that did not that was born would be
born that would disadvantage her and it
would be disadvantaged and all of that
because no father you know around to
support them and all of that stuff right
it's not even just not a crime to lie
about birth control it's written into
Canadian law that a woman who sabotages
or lies about birth control cannot be
prosecuted for sexual assault and that
was written into a decision finding a
man who poked holes in the condoms
guilty of sexual assault I'd like to
back up a little bit and respectfully
push back on some of that I don't agree
with the biodeterminism in this at all
social Customs around men and women have
evolved and changed for centuries there
is it's hard for me to imagine a
significant number of men which we're
starting to see nowadays even having the
opportunity to go red pill if if this is
so biologically determined I I don't I
don't I think that's just I don't think
it serves us as a model because it takes
Choice out of the hands of men I mean
factually I think it's incorrect because
we just have so much Social history
around gynocentrism and its evolution in
socially with human beings that are
predating romantic chivalry courtly love
uh people didn't even get married for
love they got married for practicality
and yeah
but I just I mean I in the end if a guy
ends up in a place where he understands
some model some understanding
gynocentrism and can use that that model
or that knowledge to protect himself I I
think he's in good shape but I prefer a
little bit more personal control over my
destiny than biology would allow me oh
yeah no I'm I'm not saying that I'm not
saying that this is something that's
written in stone I'm saying that people
have to have a meta awareness of what's
going on in order to curtail their own
impulses and their own even even even I
even I have a problem you remember the
the Egyptian woman in the blue bra
remember that video yep even I was
horrified by that and I had to watch it
a second time to see what was going on
with the men around and how they were
getting much more brutally beaten and
lots of mras uh left comments under that
video where I talked about it and they
said they went they didn't even realize
that the men who were getting beaten in
the same frame right were completely
they they were completely oblivious to
those men and then they had to go back
and watch and see how much more brutally
those men were being treated by Egyptian
police than that one woman right and
they had to go back and watch because
they were like oh no she was like
absolutely brutally stomped when in
reality the moment her burka fell open
and they realized oh there is actually a
woman under here because a lot of men in
the Middle East will put on a burqa to
make trouble because women are
supposedly off limits for for State
violence that they uh they realized that
the moment her Burke fell open and and
it was clear that that she was a woman
one of the cops pushed another cop was
like in the process of jumping and you
know going to kick her and he pushed her
away and pushed that cop away so I have
a question so are you saying Paul you're
saying you don't think it's biological
gynocentrism I think there's biological
elements to it absolutely I don't think
we can deny that but I I think we also
to just is a biological mechanism alone
I think misses them okay you you no you
can't you can't capitulate to it I mean
like it is biological in the sense that
women want what they want when they want
it and as much as they can get you know
like yes social norms between men and
women have changed through the centuries
and all of that right but what what's
always the core pattern right think men
make the environment safe uh and then
women decide they want to go outside and
then they demand their men let them go
outside they demand their men let them
have freedom so the men say okay and
then they then women demand more and
more freedom and more and more autonomy
and more and more agency and more and
more ability to make their own decision
us and not have to be obedient or not
have to like capitulate to any kind of
restrictions and uh and then boom yeah
now you can be a fat [__] and still be
a wife and and then and then we're back
then we're back to subsistence living
where women actually have to be obedient
to their husbands because they actually
really depend on their husbands and not
things aren't safe and nothing's
plentiful and everybody's starving and
and this is why KW Elder said 2 000
years ago if you make women your equals
they'll become your Masters that's right
right so um you said before a thousand
years ago there was no romantic love
I mean there was infatuation I think
that always has the release of oxytocin
and chemical infatuation bonding between
human beings was always there but it was
regarded as a form of insanity generally
socially and and
people saw no reason the idea of getting
married based on that infatuation would
be was considered absolute Insanity it
just yeah your parents would be so
disappointed absolutely but then a woman
Eleanor about contained her daughter
Marie commissioned Troubadours spread
the word of romantic love and its
elevation above all other forms of Love
um and it caught on and it's it has come
to be our standard ever since yeah no
and and what I find interesting about
that too is that it's elevated above all
other forms of Love including the love
of God
which you know
yeah even as an atheist right I I can
say you know for the time that was a
pretty ballsy statement and really
really I I can't even imagine how she
wasn't like strung up on a rat I mean
wasn't weren't they still burning it's
because William
um her uh her her father I I believe her
father or grandfather grandfather
um was I think the world's first simp uh
carrying an image of his mistress on his
shield into battle uh and he was what
inspired them they grew up watching him
simp for all the women in his court uh
and they turned it into a cottage
industry that spread throughout the
world and does that work because I I had
this thought wondering if proposals were
almost gynocentric because earlier I was
thinking more like feminist because the
guy's like going below the woman and I
never I never thought about it it's like
he's on his knee yeah I was like he's on
his knees begging yeah
to be his economic dependent for the
rest of his life and he's purchasing her
with a ring that cost him three months
salary well and even I had a thought I
started Googling the average price of a
wedding and I was thinking about how the
price of weddings has gone up but the
value of brides is like so low because I
I had this thought where because I got
into the red pill and they're like want
modern women bring nothing and I'm like
what do you mean we bring nothing and
and then I started going through the
stats and I was like oh [__] we've like
as a group one out of three of us had an
abortion one out of three has an STD I'm
like we have like one point something
kids I'm like God damn this is not good
with a shout out to Aaron Clary there's
lots of women who want to get married
and have families there's very few who
want to be wives and mothers yeah yeah
that that was really the the thing you
know like it wasn't hard for me to find
my first husband uh you know he find a
man who was willing to actually go into
a marriage a very traditional marriage
right with stay-at-home mom at least in
as much as possible financially and even
when I went back to work uh our kids
never went to daycare uh they were never
with a babysitter they you know I just
took jobs that were on opposite shifts
from my husband and he stayed home one
of us was home with them and uh and you
know I did a whole bunch of really
traditional things uh around the house
you know I cooked from scratch I bought
cloth diapers that you have to hold fold
and pin you know I I rescued and
refurbished Furniture I did everything I
possibly could to squeeze every bit of
value out of every single penny so that
I could afford to stay home and uh but
you know it's it's very very difficult I
think to find a woman these days who
would be willing to not just do all of
those things domestically including
being the hand man around the house and
things like that plunging your own
toilet and and all of those things
because this is what you know I was
basically a farm wife living in a small
town
um but uh it's hard to find a woman like
that and uh and it's hard to find a
woman who's who's willing to actually
commit to that lifestyle right like so
to find one com you can't even find a
woman who can cook these days half the
time right you know they know how to
microwave a Lean Cuisine that's about it
and um yeah like they and they and one
who's willing to commit long-term right
like long term at least until the kids
are basically grown and uh next to
impossible to find somebody who actually
wants to do those things
um it was not hard for me to find a man
who wanted to live that way yeah that's
right that's what I found but there's
God there's been positive in that though
in that uh you know in my household I'm
in a relationship of 21 years now very
happily connected in that way but uh I I
am the cook in the house because I don't
want to eat inferior food
that's that's what my oldest says he
says uh he's the cook because uh he and
my daughter live together they share a
duplex and
um they're because they're like 15
months apart like they're just like
uh joined at the hip kind of and um but
yeah he does all the cooking because he
wouldn't eat this the swill that Rachel
makes so but you know something I I
gotta say
yeah and I hope women someday wake up to
this if you can be replaced by somebody
who can push a broom and use a skillet
maybe you're not bringing enough to a
relationship yeah yeah no if he can if
he can pay uh 200 300 a week to have
somebody come in and do those services
including the dick sucking
um
once a week uh then
you know like why are you here right you
you have to you have to actually bring
some kind of and you know sex is part of
that of course because
um
no no man gets married just praying that
he'll never have sex again yeah well
that was awesome that was like a red
pill too I was like are these wives not
sleeping with their husbands I was like
what it's so kind I didn't realize how
cool it was like I started introducing
these guys in divorce and it was always
like the same story it was like oh she
it was like an accidental pregnancy
early on then he marries her and then
she just stopped sleeping with him after
the kids I was like what the hell yeah
stop sleeping with him he'll go sexless
for three years and then she'll wig up
because she finds out he's looking at
porn yeah wow yeah that's that's the
insane thing yeah no this this Madam in
Australia she wrote a piece in I think
it was a Sydney Morning Herald or
something like that where she basically
was saying wives be better right because
she says she she wrote that half of her
escorts
right when they go on a date there's not
even any sex they lie in bed with the
guy and cuddle and he tells them all of
his heart's deepest Secrets across the
pillow because he can't safely disclose
those things to his wife he does not
feel safe to do that and I'm like Jesus
Christ so these guys are paying like 200
an hour for somebody to talk to pillow
therapy do you know what I started
asking guys I'd be like okay if you're
on a first date and a girl just said to
you I don't know anything I know nothing
but I'm willing to learn would you go on
another date with her they're all like
yeah that sounds amazing I'm like oh no
I would [__] test her a lot more than
that yeah well but you'd go you'd go on
I know but I was just thinking I was
just thinking thinking like wow that's
like the bar is so low they're like I
can teach her she listens that's it
well I tell you what that's more than a
lot of guys get yeah do you think
feminism was responsible for the
breakdown of relationships today or do
you think it started before that Senator
I think it's a synergism of
sort of the the modern day simp and
feminism I mean it's really easy to
point the finger at feminism it's such a
corrupt ideology practiced by very
corrupt selfish narcissistic often
personality disordered people so it's an
easy target and it's certainly deserving
of the criticism that it gets uh but I
think that the the social gynocentrism
that we practice today the the the way
men just capitulate to totally
disrespecting themselves life on their
knees groveling before women that is a
really big problem I would argue worse
than feminism wait so just quick I have
a couple examples of that well I I think
that um I'll give you a a short story as
an example I was Furniture shopping with
my partner a few years back and we were
picking out a new sofa for the living
room
and the salesman happened to be an
African-American man I'd say in his
mid-40s uh had a
[Music]
crucifix on his lapel nice Armani suit
very short dress guy and he's showing us
around and three or four times he made
reference saying we all know who's
making the decision here don't we
yeah his his implication was that I had
no voice in this purchase that I was
about to make that I had to defer to her
and I finally turned to him and said you
know what that's not how it works here
and he was shocked he was absolutely
stunned that I said something like that
that's one of 10 million examples man if
you want to see
simping go on Twitter
you'll see it everywhere guys running to
the rescue of the most vicious nasty
hoes you can possibly imagine guys
rushing in to defend her honor and to
defend all women's honor Paul something
you can actually do but she's absolutely
disgusting it's the most disgusting to
me these guys are worse than men who who
actually do abuse women and they're much
more common much more common you think
they're worse than men that abuse women
yes I do I think they do more damage
yeah and what they wrote role model to
young men to boys and the girls in terms
of what their expectations are of men
they set future men up to have to
emulate that behavior in order to stay
in good social graces yeah yeah and I
think I think that yeah no I think
because the reason that it is the reason
it's more dangerous the reason it's more
uh Insidious is because it is considered
the socially appropriate way for men to
behave
um you know everybody everybody is
horrified when a man strikes a woman
when a man hits a woman everybody is
like there's no normalizing that you go
back a hundred two hundreds four
hundreds 500 years nobody liked it when
that happened right nobody at all not
even the Catholic church in the 1450s
right
um they did not like spousal abuse they
did not like anybody any man raising a
hand to any woman
um it was just not something that was
considered socially acceptable people
would turn and look away they would
pretend not to see it
but they had to turn and look away from
it they weren't saying yeah yeah you
tell her how it is hit punch her again
they weren't doing that they weren't
doing that
right
but now they'll freak out if you
disagree with a woman yeah
yelling is abuse now I guess that's what
Crowder was just abusing his wife you
know although for the silent the silent
treatment is also spousal abuse but
gaslighting I learned this I'm like
using to talk to her yes oh isn't that
stonewalling no they say these
psychologists make up these like crazy
terms I'm like what the hell that sounds
like a good a term as any I haven't
heard stonewalling but I don't doubt
that they're using it because they you
can take any normal form of behavior in
men and it will be called abusive and
the opposite of that behavior will be
called abusive too so it just it really
doesn't matter well and it's interesting
I I didn't under I think the first time
we talked I was like wow this guy I
really hates soup but it's weird it's
like once you once you like see it you
can't unsee it where you're like [__]
they're just like lying like women it's
like okay we're just such idiots I mean
I like I mean not all of us but a lot
like we just believed damn near anything
it's so crazy but it's like the guys
like they know so I'm like why are you
lying like they'll come at my show and
say they like women that have slept
around they'll come on the show and say
there's nothing wrong with their 37 year
old sister who's never dated anybody and
I'm just like like you know that's not
true like why it's just like once you
see it you just can't because I'm like
do I hate you still the people that say
women can do anything men can do oh God
kindly untrue it's it's so untrue that
it's it's laughable laughably untrue and
the whole of society will nod their
heads like bobbleheads oh yeah no when
Barack Obama said a woman can do
anything a man can do
uh and better and in heels and
everybody's like oh yeah yeah
oh yeah and I'm just like are you are
you freaking kidding me get up there in
that cherry picker and fix that power
pole [__]
Sports so like uh I'm like you realize
how much stronger dudes are I'm like I'm
like top one percent if you look at how
tall I am strength it's probably similar
I could dad lift like 300 pounds that's
a lot for a chick but for a chick do I
mean like even an average guy can out
bench me you know what I mean like it's
not
and it's like I've trained 16 years to
out bench or out deadlift like I don't
know a couple guys maybe who don't train
and are obese like yeah yeah yeah I know
and it's like you're looking at the
Canadian uh Olympic uh women's hockey
team you know they spar with um not even
[__] AAA but uh basically the up to 15
year old category
is 15 to 18. and uh they practice with
them and they routinely lose the
Australian women's soccer team they
train they they train against uh 15 and
under boys teams and they routinely lose
and they all they do is stand they whine
about the pay when I'm like you're lucky
to even have a league like yeah
like they complain about the pay that
they're actually getting by siphoning
off of men's sports which is exactly
what happens that is I literally said I
was like if I was the guys I would just
cut it because I was like they all we do
is complain and [__] about the pain I'm
like I would just cut it I would just
cut the whole league you want to [__]
about it and I loved sports but I'm like
no one's watching it yeah well and and
the the idea that you're gonna get the
idea that you're gonna get male fans of
say the NBA right of basketball
to watch women's basketball
is is laughable I mean maybe there will
be some
um but not a lot and women just
generally aren't sports fans in
particular right like they I went to a
hockey game once it was we don't
normally go to even though my husband
was a hockey player and and you know he
uh he he really likes the sport
um we don't we don't go to hockey games
but uh it was part of a Christmas party
or something like that that his uh his
employers bought everybody hockey
tickets and we went there we were seated
next to these two couples
and the guys were like totally into the
game and the two women with their
probably 200 a piece tickets seats just
sat there and gossiped the whole time
they didn't even notice when someone
scored my dad's totally done that with
me where they he brings me to like
really good like seats for like a game
or whatever I don't care and I played
Sports and I don't even like watching it
to high dollar sporting events and
gossip through the whole thing all have
in common is that they did not pay for
those tickets oh yeah yeah no I go with
my dad well I mean like I I was on my
feet cheering and stuff because hey this
is my hometown it's my hometown team
Edmonton Oilers and they were playing
real good against the Vancouver Canucks
and I hated the [__] Vancouver
Canucks and uh because they betrayed me
but um with their stupid goalie Dan clue
Jay curse you but
um but yeah no I actually had to stop
watching hockey for about 10 years
because of that guy back when I was
living in British Columbia but uh but
yeah no it's it's like uh you you have a
very small pool of women who are
actually interested in sports in terms
of buying tickets like I'm not in terms
of buying tickets I'm not interested and
then um in terms of uh of actually
watching the games and being interested
in sports in general you know you've got
very very low numbers of women who are
who are likely to they they literally
went somebody somebody literally went
out on the street and offered somebody a
free ticket to uh a WNBA game or uh one
dollar bill
and the dude took the one dollar bill it
was okay you just went around people I
played I think maybe and they all took
the dollar bill you know so funny I'm 26
about 27. I think I started playing
basketball when I was like six or seven
I played for 20 years I would pick the
hundred dollar bill well it was a one
dollar bill or something
way less value than the ticket I think
the ticket was only one I'm curious how
has social media changed relationships
between men and women because when I
when social media came to the scene I
was pretty young so I think I got my
first like Facebook when I was in eighth
grade so I was like 12 maybe so it like
as far as I really remember social media
has just always been there but I'm
curious from your point of view like how
has I just changed it for the better
really uh yeah I think we're seeing the
beginnings of changes for the better the
thing that is so great about social
media is that the alternative narrative
to this romantic model this gynocentric
[__] that's been running the world
is that that stuff would never be
expressed first in real word real real
world terms you would not you don't have
people at parties you know talking about
screw marriage I would never ever trust
a woman with all my assets and walk into
the family courts that's not party
discourse in real world terms but
through social media we have the
opportunity to spread information and to
talk about an alternative way for men to
view their own lives in ways that we've
never had before it's why we have red
pill movements why we have Midtown it's
why we've got a lot of things going on
that would you know there was like
versions of of mgtow in the past
bachelor's clubs and stuff like that
very very small portion of the
population very local yeah and nowadays
it's it's worldwide and it's amazing how
many men actually do start rethinking
their own lives when when they start
getting exposed to information that
makes them see things that they've been
trained to not see their whole lives I
think it has a great positive impact in
that way it's going to be rough and
bloody at first I think men need to I
honestly we're seeing men now finally
getting in touch with their anger about
this lopsided deal that they've always
had and that sentiment is growing
there's going to be growing pains
involved in that and we're talking about
you know we talked about the the
slowness of this before keep in mind
that from Seneca Falls until women got
Voting Rights was 70 years and it was
another 40 50 years after that before
gender feminism raised its ugly head in
society these things are like big
lumbering ships they're not like sports
cars that turn on a dime and change
directions but it's happening and I
think it's happening on a bigger scale
it's why you see so much panic in the
so-called conservative right about men
who won't get married and who are
challenging all this stuff
this is starting to scare people which
it ought to do yeah no I I would say too
I mean like social media has turned
dating into Twitter you know and and not
just social media but like these dating
apps Bumble and Tinder and grinder and
all of that stuff I mean even online
dating even internet dating is not what
it was when I was doing it when I met my
husband my the one that just put coffee
in the microwave if I freeze up that's
why it really has sort of cheapened the
whole process of dating but it's also I
think woken a lot of men uh to the fact
that you know you can you can be a
reasonably attractive guy a six or a
seven uh you can have a good income you
can have you know be in a good place in
your life you know like I I own a condo
and uh and I work as
um as a technician or an engineer or
something like that and I make 80k a
year and and I'm I'm doing good and I'm
debt free and all of that stuff right
and swipe left swipe left swipe left
woman after woman swipe left swipe left
because you're five ten you're not six
feet tall right or because you're uh you
have a bit of a uh of a big nose or you
know or you're not uh you haven't it's
it's oh they'll only date six and six
six feet six figures right and and
that's it so I think it's I think not
just social media and the spreading of
the word on social medias or the
democratization of information that
occurs through social media it's not
just that it's men's experience of
women's
absolute pickiness and their their
unbelievably high standards so you got
you've got an overweight woman right who
says I won't date anyone less than six
feet tall and if the guy yeah how much
do you weigh they won't date fat guys
either have interviewed these checks oh
I know I know and you know like I used
to write smut for women right and there
was a whole genre of smut for women
called BBW big beautiful woman and she
was always lizzo and he was always
freaking Brad Pitt yeah I I just thought
to dovetail a little bit off of what
Karen just said the way I look at it is
that on the other side of men getting
better more information and seeing women
more clearly than they ever have we have
the negative effects of social media
dating apps in that you have women's
that are literally threes and fours who
behave and act like they're eights and
nines because of all the attention they
get through dating apps they
misinterpret this flood of male
attention which is just how men are uh
chasing women they misinterpret that as
making them more valuable than they are
I'm sure a lot of those women don't get
any dates at all that are ever going to
satisfy them well right well they start
to think they look like they're filters
it's like a weird phenomenon no I swear
Excel these girls will come on my show
and I'm like I'll be talking to them and
sometimes I'll follow them on Instagram
after and I'm like who is this
or sometimes they'll take a picture like
with me after the show and I don't
really use filters like that but they
they'll it's like automatic when you
take a picture and I'm like God damn
like this just gave me like two points
this is amazing like I'm like but they
start to think they're actually that hot
with these filters they like
automatically make your nose a little
smaller your smile a little wider your
skin a little smoother I'm like I think
these chicks like literally think they
look like that yeah no and I'm looking
at myself right now and it's like I
haven't worn makeup in 10 years and you
know there's this thing it runs in my
dad's family
um where once you hit 50
what used to be flatteringly described
as natural eye shadow
because I never had to wear eye shadow
because I always had natural darker
coloring on my eyelids right now it just
becomes raccoon eyes and um yeah no so
I'm I'm looking at myself and I'm just
like well what the [__] do I care I'm 52
years old I'm not on the market now
these like you'll see these like Madonna
50 something year old chicks where
they're like they're it's like you know
yeah stretch stretch real tight yeah no
they've had that's that's so appealing
yeah they've had they've had 13
adjustments of their little pranks to
like pull the I'm like 30 years
the leather face a little bit tighter
well and they were trying to Market
um Botox to me like in my early 20s like
I I had yeah and I'm like what the [__]
what do I need both I'm like 24 like I'm
in 27 now almost but back then I was
like I was 24 I'm like you're ready you
want me to get on boat like what's that
gonna look like in 20 30 years you're
gonna be like frozen yeah
the bow portion of botox's botulism
and the talks part of Botox is Toxin
botulism toxins what do you what do you
I'm curious what you guys see for the
future because like for me it's
interesting because I have I have like
ideas of policies that I think were bad
so like I don't think women really
should have voted I'm not really a fan
of no fault divorce but part of me is
like I don't know if you can go back and
maybe like there's ways they have to
adapt into the future so I I don't know
I'm not I'm not actually sure exactly
what policies I prescribe moving forward
except that women shouldn't vote but but
I'm curious like what you guys think I
don't know if my my thoughts on that is
I don't Focus so much on policy I really
I think Min Solutions certainly aren't
political or legal I don't want to start
building
state-funded battered men shelters or or
anything like that but what I I think
has to happen in the few future and
probably will happen is that men and
women will have to renegotiate a social
contract at some point to something that
is more fair and I would also say I
think there's going to be a long time
before that happens where women find out
what it's like to live in a population
of men who are angry and don't give a
[__] about their problems I think that's
coming we've got young men in high
school now are staunchly anti-feminist
and moving to the right
and yet they're not embracing
traditional gynocentrism at all
when this generation of men that
generation comes of age some women are
going to get some very rude Awakenings
and the the sad part of it is and I know
some guys will tell me Paul it's not sad
it's sad to me is that the women who are
going to ultimately suffer for the sins
of their mothers and grandmothers and
great-grandmothers are not the ones who
did this stuff but they're still going
to be the ones left in the Lurch when
men quit participating in this rigged
game so you you think that men are Gonna
Keep like start walking away from
Marriage walking away from relationships
walking away from children they've
already started yeah yeah no I agree
until the the I mean it's it's like that
that uh recent report came out 63
percent of young men uh haven't even
tried to go on a date in the last year
they're walking away all right and
they're angry you can't be brought up in
a North American school system as a male
and and not have some repressed anger or
some expressed anger out of that because
these guys have been [__] on their their
whole academic lives uh it's it is and I
agree with Karen I think it'll have to
collapse first uh but the beginning of
the collapse is when men generally
speaking start withdrawing support from
women when they start taking care of
themselves every everything is going to
go to hell so especially for us so with
with I'm curious like what would a more
fair contract look like and what is the
collapse gonna look like okay well a
more fair contract I think would be
something that could be negotiated
between
Partners right like
if I mean like we my husband and I we
have a verbal like a handshake deal and
we trust each other to hold up our ends
of the bargain and then if things get a
little bit untenable for one of us we
will sit down at the bargaining table
and see if we need to renegotiate
right and that's how we do things and we
actually look at we actually kind of
approach the relationship very similar
to a contract it's it's it is actually
you know this is what I agreed to do
that's what you agreed to do so part of
that might actually be introducing
something that Muslims have been doing
for uh Ages which is
um the not the bride gift but the actual
contract where you hash out exactly
what's expected of each partner
um before you tie the knot but honestly
I think that uh I think that one of the
things that you could do policy wise
that would really put a damper on
women's willingness to throw away
marriages is default shared parenting
right because you know you can only read
so many articles with titles like the
agony of being a 50 50 Mom very
sympathetic all these poor women right
they missed their they might have missed
their daughter's first steps or their
son's first words because he was they
were with their dad at the time right
and you know and she has to share a
custody 50 with her her ex-husband and
and it's just so horrible for these
women Well yeah if it's that horrible
that's freaking implement it and maybe
these women won't be so quick to throw
away their husbands I personally uh I
think a part of the negotiation is an
individual thing
um 25 years ago I made the decision that
hey if you're gainfully employed you
better find your [__] person when the
check arrives and and carry your share
because I don't care if I had 10 million
in the bank I wouldn't finance a
relationship with a woman
um and I I and there were times but
before I met my current partner that
yeah I sprang for a couple of dinners so
I could get sex
okay no problem uh it wasn't well
received in the end but you know that's
the game I chose to play it better than
they did uh but for me it starts with
with personal accountability financially
if you have to show up bringing your
your labor your sweat to the
relationship in order to help build it
it gives you a better investment in it
and it it doesn't end up with men
getting used for their money uh there's
nothing that that I hate more than to
hear a woman complain just because you
bought me dinner doesn't mean you get to
have sex well then pay for your own
[__] dinner yeah
if you don't want to hear that [__] from
them pay your own money and of course if
you if you insisted now I lost I went
through probably 20 women before I met
my partner who once they came up against
that Financial wall decided they weren't
so interested in me and that was just
fine with me because I saved myself
another divorce rope
by going for a little bit better class
of woman if a woman expects to be able
to make money and to pay her own bills
and to have her own autonomy
but not contribute to a relationship
financially she's a hoe yep do you think
there'll ever be a return to
traditionalism yes yeah I do too you
know like okay 33 trillion 33.1 trillion
in debts not a whole lot better in
Canada my kids my older two kids were
born each with owing 38 000 in taxpayer
debt during covid that went up to more
than one hundred thousand dollars that
all three of my kids oh
to Future creditors to people collecting
on those debts in the future so you know
you're looking at it the system that
we've set up that basically it sticks a
an expensive bloated bureaucratic
middleman in between men and women so
where whereas a man and a woman would
get together and they would bargain they
would decide between them how they
wanted their relationship to work and
who does what and all of those things
right and they would get together they
would raise children what we'd now have
is a situation where you have this
gigantic bloated money-hungry middleman
taking a cut of every transfer of money
that goes from men to women I mean like
when you look at child support laws
title 4D basically what that did was it
said well for every dollar of child
support money a State Child Support
Agency can extract forcibly extract from
a man they will get a dollar in Federal
transfers so the state is basically what
the state does is they say okay well
we're we're going to pay for you to be
on welfare and support your kids but we
don't want to pay the whole cost of that
right so we're going to go after the
father of these kids and extract every
single penny of child support money we
can from him and we're going to deduct
that off of your welfare check so the
children will be no better off but we
will because then for every dollar we
extracted from that man we get another
dollar from the federal government in
grant money yay Federal transfers we've
doubled our money by nailing men to the
wall and letting women do whatever the
[__] they want and nobody's better off
everybody's worse off and this whole
system is only held together by the
illusion of our great grandchildren's
projected productivity that's it that's
it that's all that's holding it together
33.1 trillion dollars that falls on the
working people today and next generation
and the Next Generation and the next one
right to pay that back or just let it
keep ballooning and once we can no
longer afford to pay to sustain this
system and men and women have to go back
to actually bargaining as individuals as
to what they want their relationships to
look like and and work like and all of
that right then you're going to see some
women willing to actually sit down at
the negotiating table because they don't
have that bureaucratic muscle standing
behind them going now you're going to
pay and you're going to pay what we tell
you how long do you think it'll be till
that happens until they stop like
backing up women's bad decisions with
child support alimony and government I
hope it's I hope it's till the day after
I die yeah yeah no me too like I I well
I I hope it when my kids die if I don't
have grandchildren because like it's
gonna be it's not going to be a pleasant
transition women are going to be so used
to getting all of this free stuff you
know know and when you look at New
Zealand and the the numbers they came
out with a few years ago where they
actually looked at the cumulative
contribution into the tax system of men
and women right from birth to death
right and they found that the only
people who actually pay taxes who
actually pay net taxes are men between
the ages of 4 and 65 40 and 65. that's
when those are the only people who are
actually contributing putting in more
than they take out and they Peak at 65
in in terms of their net contribution
and that's when when they retire and
then they start pulling out of the
system and by the time they're 80
they're at zero they have made no net
contribution how do you sustain that
right and women never get above negative
fifty thousand dollars right I don't
think anybody can really predict with
any kind of accuracy when it's going to
win but I do believe that it will happen
and when it does it's going to be
incredibly fast and Incredibly ugly and
then you will see the negotiations
between men and women for the social
contract are going to change radically
after that collapse it'll be like oh
it's going to be just like the women
like run to their friend zone
they're like they're like oh [__] you
know all those years they put you in the
friend zone I don't know what I was
thinking yeah
I was so silly I just didn't recognize
how hot you were yeah yeah you're you're
the Tom Hanks to my makeup you know what
you're like the hottest guy I've ever
seen in my life ever I just don't even
because you're the one who's likely to
touch my vagina and like protect me
thank you guys for coming on the guy
this is actually interesting because
I've been thinking a lot about like what
you know the future holds with
everything that's going on so it's kind
of interesting to talk to people that
have had a little bit more time to think
about this stuff so um thank you guys
both for coming on um could you tell the
people where they could find you okay
you can find me at paulleelam.com but
more importantly go to paulilam.com
forward slash XY crew and read up about
what we're doing with our men's groups
talking about all of this stuff and
figuring out how we're dealing with this
new life it's great stuff you can join
us there and you can find me on my
channel girl writes What on YouTube it's
fairly defunct but it has like a massive
hours and hours and hours of back
catalog that are could easily serve and
I was actually learning when I was doing
those so I mean it would be like a great
primer for anybody who's interested in
any of these things to kind of go back
and watch watch those videos in order
and you can also find me on the site
formerly known as Prince I mean Twitter
under at girl writes what and I also
have a Blog that I rarely post on but
occasionally do called
owningyourshit.blogspot.com
um you can go there and I have a very
recent post uh that details all the
reasons why yeah also please come follow
me on Twitter at Rio Paul Elum at real
Paul Elum yeah he's always he's always
out of the blue check mark I'll have you
know yeah oh he's always adding these
simps too it's awesome I'm always
retweeting we went on the daily why this
weekend it was all it was awesome I was
like this is amazing I went from
watching these guys to tweeting at him
and then recognizing me I'm like what a
day yeah no the The Sims The Sims really
need to be uh saved yeah right they need
to be rescued from themselves yeah well
and it's also like oh my gosh once you
can't you can't unsee it like the
nagging wife so it's like you can kind
of you can kind of see who's like
controlled by their wives based on like
the things they say or like because
they're all mad their daily wire was mad
a couple months ago because I put let me
ask my wife with a barfing Emoji next to
it
they are easily triggered they're like
and they're like well what if she's my
assistant and I'm like I mean I have an
assistant I
see don't ask her like like I tell her
what I'm doing I don't ask her you know
what I mean like I might not like I
might ask like what am I like what's the
schedule this week but I'm not asking
permission
yeah you can make a make a lousy sip
yeah yeah I know
um okay guys um make sure you go follow
subscribe to both of them and get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
today look these women we've just gotten
out of control you know I I might even
make a simp shouldn't vote t-shirt
either I know you've got I've heard you
I it's not just women okay but it's
gotta start with the women because it's
just I don't even understand these
campaigns we just believe anything you
see the clothes they convince us to wear
like this is crazy all right um all
right so like the video guys subscribe
to the channel um thank you guys for
coming on and I'll talk to you next time
[Music]